hello and welcome to the co playing
chess with chess with okay continuing to
experiment a little bit with 14 without
really extensive knowledge with the g3 I
had a good position again age five why
are they all playing age five that
really good I mean I know it's this is
kind of a playable move but still how to
do that yeah I'm not sure of age four is
cool probably not yeah the Bishop c5 now
this is this is the thing this is the
problem that's not good
now anyway it's not like I'm terribly
verse or anything it's still interesting
position okay so I want to do this yeah
maybe you can even go be fine and but 95
isn't that working here 95 you takes it
takes I'm threatening v6 and the night
hangs d6r take take lady six okay
if UD six now and Bishop b5 and pawn d 6
i'll take you five point XD six maybe
there are intermediate moves here funky
stuff Bishop g4
move it if I play Bishop takes c6 there
should be two bishops e7 should have one
look f1 then I'm a fantastic play for
the exchange check the two points for
the exchange and i have d 6 coming up it
should make my deep on fantastically
strong so would be 61 not yeah I think
I'll go for that it's not even clear
whether the rook is going create
probably Bishop c6
I can still sacrifice okay let's keep
this
interesting
to try to keep it with night a six then
that should be quite good for right here
if not if not more
yeah black probably can't escape to some
ending up on down not a good nothing
great but yeah like here if I'm you
should be seven for example it would be
and ending a pawn down but this sound
this is stronger
9847 intending we should be so yeah so
this one
yeah you can cantique now play we should
be seven and then it sir it's an ending
with the poem check okay I should play
this quicker really because this is very
very nice and I should just play this a
little bit quicker
my 2016 and estimated that time warning
you
check
kjetil it still should should be a win
okay okay okay so I cannot do that check
check i miss played that really badly
very stupid very stupid plane ah now I'm
blundering this that so quickly gets
more more weird weirder yeah I didn't
really pay any attention the beginning
of this ending yeah what about a crap
game really you have a completely
winning position easily winning position
gain dry how idiotic can you play really
I just think a little bit in this ending
instead of just playing a couple of
idiotic moves I can win this so easily
if I just think for a moment this is
just completely embarrassing not to win
something like I just have to play like
see-through before or something else fix
this on a light square and then you win
this in your sleep it's just so easy aah
i didn't pay any attention i was just
thinking okay whatever you been here
anyway you know of course I mean it
still wins but it just it just takes
longer and I'm unnerved yeah by having
this I know I can obviously go see five
here what did that play c5 just c5 check
anyway check check check yeah I don't
know I was right lately pissed by that
time that it came to that it wasn't even
a bad game this is the bed the most
annoying thing you actually see some
interesting ideas like 95 and then you
don't win this the simple endgame simple
ending it's interesting that this
doesn't even work I mean bishop you
should g4 just just lose us but he can
take this interestingly enough and this
is good for black very interesting
because he's got this all of a sudden of
course I didn't see that and my bishop
he is trapped so my interesting idea was
actually bad and this just scientist
just should loose and the position at
least is losing for black t6 and they
are probably probably easier wins okay
this is fairly easy I mean
t3 also as possible yeah but ok and this
is just an easily winning ending if you
just fix the pawns on dark squares or I
mean by now I was already unnerved that
I had allowed this Buddhist nonsense and
yeah anyway ok guys I have to recoup new
game thanks for watching